[Music]
penguin does not look so different from
Scotland they are sisters
Queen Elizabeth your cousin Mary has
returned to take up her throne in
Scotland the Queen
my dear cousin Elizabeth I hope we might
meet in person as I might embrace you
but ruling side-by-side we must do so in
harmony not through a treaty drafted by
men lesser than ourselves
my dear cousin that our nation's
cherished each other as we would two
kingdoms United how did the world come
to this wise men servicing the whims of
women
Mary is our phone we must never bound to
her as we bow before you
you have the boldness to doubt my
judgment she is only your queen if I
should not produce it now why does he
play to have a man booth
[Music]
with heavens blessings we bring an heir
to Scotland and to England
it is a clear provocation when you must
make war in Scotland oh so put your
skills to use
do not play into their hands our hatred
is precisely what they hope for I know
your heart has more within it than the
men who can't fill you you would do well
to watch or work I will not be scolded
by my inferior your barrier be afraid
Henry no good because our swords are not
just for sure
we have a scourge upon our land
there's a woman with a clone
Beauty bravery now I see here's no
clothes and me
your gifts will be your downfall
should you murder me remember you murder
your sister and you murder your queen
[Music]
you
[Music]